you
why don't people have power and having
answered that question now approximately
a billion times I am pretty well ready
to answer it for you which is the
biggest barrier I think for us having
power is of course ourselves we are own
biggest barrier to having power we are
oftentimes not willing to do what it
takes or to make the trade-offs required
to have power we limit ourselves by
being afraid to take chances or to fail
so many of my friends graduate from
Stanford Business School and they follow
the well-trod has of their predecessors
you know which I've never made much
sense to me which is why would you go to
the same firms that hire all of the best
and brightest from all the same schools
that you're graduating from go find a
niche isn't that what they teach you in
competitive strategy but you know so we
we oftentimes are willing to take the
chances required we worry excessively
about what others particularly peers
think about us we want to be liked by
everybody or loved even and therefore
you know and it's a very interesting
fine line that you want to walk
obviously you want to be liked and you
want to be popular but on the other hand
what I try to teach the students and
what I try to get them to understand is
that if you think about it in a very
simple common-sense way your peers your
direct hierarchical peers are also your
competitors if you think about you know
your start off day one class of
associates at a law firm a class of
people at Goldman or Morgan Stanley
class of people at McKinsey Bain BCG all
these firms have an upper out and even
if they don't have an upper out sooner
or later some of you are going to get
promoted to the next level and some of
you won't so it is in fact the case that
your peers are also your competitors and
so maybe you no need to think about them
in a variety of different ways we
reluctant to accept status and
hierarchical differences my friend and
colleague DEVGRU Feld who teaches here
will tell you we live in a hierarchical
world and we're oftentimes
uncomfortable with hierarchy many of us
are counter dependent certainly
describes me which is why I've got a
good job at Stanford Business School we
don't like to have people telling us
what to do many of us so we so we
rebelled against you know our high we
were Bell against hierarchical Authority
other people get in positions of power
and they say why do I have the right to
tell people below me what to do and they
try to give up their power so I think
we're uncomfortable in hierarchy even
though we live in hierarchies all the
time we see the world is fair and just
and therefore we are less vigilant and
strategic than required one of the
common things when I teach people the
cases that I teach them about is I often
get this comment well you know these
people will get it in the end so I don't
need I'll have anything to learn from
them because sooner or later their bad
behavior will catch up with them in fact
because the world is not a just and fair
place every religious tradition that I
know has some account balancing scheme
the deal to deal with it you know later
on you know in some cases it's heaven in
hell in some cases it is reincarnation
in some cases it's Karma every will and
every religious tradition has this for
the same reason because it isn't you
know it is an adjust in fair world and
so how do we make sense of this except
by having some account balancing scheme
but this makes us I think because we
believe in a just world we oftentimes
don't pay attention to the more
interesting people in the organization
in the early 1980s I visited at Harvard
Business School and taught their version
of this class which by the way is not
nearly as good Carl Patton
while power and influence with my dear
friend and colleague John Cotter and
John would say to the students and I
think he was completely right he'd say
you know he said you all want to learn
from the people who look brilliant and
have amazing levels of interpersonal
skill and have succeeded he said the
people you really ought to learn from
other people who look to you like they
have no skill whatsoever hmm either
interpersonally or in business but have
nonetheless have made it to the top they
have something else and it would be
interesting in some ways to learn what
that is and how they have maneuvered his
point being that anybody can succeed if
you are a genius and fabulous and
successful and interpersonally competent
but it takes real political skill to
succeed when you have none of those
attributes and he by the way is right at
the inside is important to be able to
learn from all kinds of people and to be
able to accept all kinds of people which
i think you know we don't because we see
the rule is just we become way too
judgmental um we are willing to make the
trade-offs required to acquire power
being liked all the time versus getting
things done I think that's you know I
can still recall being on a Dean search
committee many years ago and it was a
comment that the preceding Dean was a
nice person but we weren't going
anywhere and as I pointed out the nice
thing about being dead in the water is
that no one could complain about the
direction and that as soon as you start
to broked metaphorically speaking
someone will say regardless of the
evidence and the data this isn't how I
think we should be going and so there is
this issue of you know as if you won't
be like where everybody don't do
anything as soon as you make a decision
some people will like it and some people
won't how we spend our time and focus
our attention strategic versus fun
interactions and relationships are you
willing to pay the price of having power
and there's an enormous price for having
power my dear friend Rudy crew has been
through at least two maybe three
marriages you know he works all the time
most successful people that I know have
to work very very hard and that's true
whether you're running a non-profit or
for-profit you look at the people
we'll go into government and the one
thing you can say you may like their
policies or not like their policies
they're all working enormous Li long and
hard hours to be in a position like this
you f do you have to pay a price you
have to decide am I willing to work this
hard and to interact with people who I
need to interact with rather than the
people who I perhaps want to interact
with you know so I like to tell people
I'm in a job with relatively low
interdependence I can have lunch with my
friends if you want to have power you
need to figure out who you need to have
lunch with metaphorically strategically
in order to get things done and build
the relationships that will make you
successful and I you know I would come
into class and we teach on Monday and
Friday and you know it became like a
joke finally when I would say to the
students I'd say well how did you spend
your weekend and they would kind of look
at me like you know what kind of a
doofus is this we spent our weekend you
know partying or skiing or doing
whatever they do with their close
friends with their roommates with their
colleagues and I wanted out to them that
if you spend all your time with your
current close friends how do you ever
make new ones and in fact there's a lot
of research that shows that the most
useful ties that you will develop are
the weak ties because your friends
travel pretty much in the same social
circles you travel in and therefore they
can provide you mostly with redundant
information and if you want non
redundant information you need to get
out of your comfort zone with the people
that you normally associate with thank
you all for being here and thank you so
much for inviting me